hazel felt like minnie was more into me
than she was into hazel
and hazel could see i was just
fascinated by many
tariq revealed that sharing a girlfriend
it's nothing new for him and hazel as a
matter of fact
the last time they tried this thing out
it didn't go so well there was like this
jealousy
that came over hazel immediately hazel
told me
to never contact minnie ever again
do you think he listened no
he didn't tarik used the old trick
of reaching out to minty to
check on her now they're communicating
again
and hazel who was set to arrive in
america soon
has no clue i'm worried that it might
mess everything up
hey 90 day fans fam happy holidays
it's malicia look i'm gonna be real with
you
i've heard of throttles but i've never
seen how they play out
and based off the latest episode of 90
day fiance
tariq and hazel prove that it's a hard
thing to do is there hot girls there
like kind of girls that i like
uh yeah i don't want you to be too happy
thinking about a girl cause you're gonna
forget about me
before we dive deeper into their
complicated situation
you know tariq's a rapper right
random but yes he is
and during this episode he gave us a
glimpse of his song
hot sauce i'm assuming
that's the name throw your hot sauce
heal the hot sauce
pretty little ghost pepper burn my mouth
off girl your hot sauce
hella hot sauce so far i can't see when
you top out
i'm a passionate person and i have many
great loves
i love music i'm actually an excellent
rapper
i'm sorry if i'm jumping the pistol but
look how your ass crystal bumping my
pistol i'm a gentleman and a scholar so
i'mma blame it on that
lemon twist vodka grow your hot sauce
hella hot sauce
okay let me stop because that song
would be stuck in my head all day and
yes i did go to my cabinet to get a
bottle of hot sauce because
why not why not you know what needs to
happen
tariq binyam and oozman should get on a
song together
the 90 day rappers and singers
i think binyam is a singer don't say
don't say
don't say don't say baby cool yeah with
all the drama they've gone through
they should be able to write a good love
song
just saying all right let's go ahead and
get into
tariq revealing how he and hazel's
ex-girlfriend
minty came into the picture so you're
just all in
i mean it's been smooth sailing since
they went
during a meet-up with his good friend
kia tariq revealed that he once broke up
with hazel
because he thought she was pregnant with
his baby
and then terminated the pregnancy
without telling him
well later he found out he was wrong
but by then he was already entertaining
a new girl on the internet from thailand
named minty you know talking to her
online i started feeling guilty
so i told that girl like yo before we
get
any further i gotta go clean this up
so when i finally did talk to hazel i
said look i'm gonna be straight up
honest with you
i started talking online you know to
this girl she was like i want to see all
the pictures i want to see all the text
messages
i was like okay i ain't got nothing hot
you know and then
she was like she's beautiful and i might
want to talk to her
like talk to her like holla at her
yeah like holla at her
oh hazel might seem shy
but what i'm learning is that when it
comes to the women that she wants
she's bold she does not hesitate to
speak up
and i'm not mad at it the only way to
get what you want
is to say it but that being said
when it comes to minty hazel asked for a
situation that ended up
backfiring on her so we met
um y'all met all three yeah we met in
the philippines
a year and a half ago so what did they
hook up did it happen
everything was beautiful for about two
and a half days
day three hazel just put an end to it
hazel felt like minnie was more into me
than she was into hazel there was like
this jealousy
that came over hazel immediately and it
ended
right there i don't get it if bringing a
person
into their relationship didn't work
before and hazel got jealous
why are they trying to do it again a new
woman
isn't gonna fix this plus tyrique
still hasn't let go of the old one that
hazel told him to get rid of
all i did was text her a couple of weeks
ago
and said yo i saw the news that
coronavirus is like
going wild there in the part of the
world you're from are you good
the next day she gets back and it's like
10 text messages
there's hazel no that you reached out to
her as
reserved and quiet as hazel is she's not
a pushover
so i'm afraid to tell hazel that i
reached out to minnie
hayles was like damn near on her way
here
and i'm worried that it might mess
everything up
eventually i have to tell hazel i'm just
not going to do it now
again i am no throttle expert
i'm not never done it don't think i ever
will no judgment though
just not for me but i'm assuming
that transparency is key when it comes
to these relationships
so i'm interested to see how hazel is
going to respond
to all of this in the meantime i spoke
with a couple
before the season 8 premiere and i had
to ask them
are they worried that one another might
fall in love with the other woman
and decide to leave their relationship
here's what they had to say if derek
fall in love
more in the girl
i think sometimes that would be ha
that will be happen sometimes you have
to throw caution to the wind
and i feel like she you know
gave up way more than i did
you know i mean she basically turned her
whole life upside down to
get oh you're gonna fall in love with a
girl and run away with the girl
you know what kind of man would i be i
got square shoulders you know everything
is in the right place right here
so it seems like hazel has the concern
and tariq is just trying to play it cool
but unlike minty this time picking the
girl
is in hazel's court so i just hope
that tariq doesn't end up feeling like
she did
well next week the couple reunites
after hazel lands in the u.s and tariq
is there to pick her
up in his very very
blue suit hazel will be here in a few
minutes and my stomach is in pretzels
i'm gonna have to bite the bullet and
tell hazel that i reached out to our
ex-girlfriend minnie
what happened ain't crying
all right 90 day fans film the saga
continues to stay updated on all the
latest news
coming out of the 90 day universe make
sure you stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i'll see
you next time
[Music]